okay let's get now to new polling that
really tells us a lot about what we need
to know about electoral strategy in 2020
there are some very good numbers for
Donald Trump we're going to get to bad
numbers for Trump a little bit later in
the show
but there are some really good numbers
from Donald Trump those numbers are that
62% of his supporters say there is
nothing he could do even hypothetically
that would cause them to abandon Donald
Trump for years I've been explaining
that most of the voting public is not
convinced about now this is on the
Democratic side and on the Republican
side in the sense that there's some
portion of the electorate that will
always vote for the Democrat there is
some portion of the electorate that will
always vote for the Republican so the
focus becomes turnout of the people that
are already on your side and also
focusing on the small portion of people
who are actually willing to see reason
and arguments and maybe change their
minds about who they're going to support
now likewise it's not just about party
because party applies to the
presidential election the Senate local
elections whatever any individual
president also has some solid unwavering
unchanging unflinching base of support
regardless of what they do
partially typically because of things
that go beyond just politics right it
could be a cult of personality
it could be ideological in some way that
that is less directly related to policy
whatever the case may be so when we look
at a presidential approval number like
40 percent the floor isn't zero I've
estimated that it's probably somewhere
between 22 and 28 percent and similarly
I've said for Donald Trump when his
approval rating wavers between 35 and 42
percent as it mostly has during his
presidency that is actually a pretty
significant swing because I don't
believe it could ever go lower than
somewhere in the range of 22 to 28
percent no matter what Donald Trump does
and there's a new poll from Monmouth
University which finds exactly that it
finds that 62 percent of Trumpets can't
think of anything they can't think of
single thing even hypothetically that
Donald Trump could do that would cause
them to reevaluate their support for him
so let's do some simple math in this
same poll Donald Trump's approval rating
is currently 43% 43% of the entire
public approves of the job that Donald
Trump is doing that's extraordinarily
disturbing and it's absolutely an
indictment of the the population of the
US but let's just deal with the number
43% of the total public approves of the
job that Donald Trump is doing 62
percent of that cohort is about 26% this
is exactly in line of what I've been
saying for a year 62 percent of Trumpets
works out to about 26 or 27 percent of
the total population who will never
abandon Donald Trump this is why
convincing Trumpets to change their
minds is a losing strategy so at the big
picture level Democratic candidates
should lay out a policy that will appeal
to people to Americans period if you lay
out a policy that simply makes sense for
Americans you're going to pick up some
Trump voters in some centrist and
whatever the case may be but as a
strategy in the nitty-gritty our goal is
to get the vote out from people who are
already on our side because remember
nearly 2/3 of the trumpets will never
change their minds even if his Donald
Trump likes to say he starts shooting
people on Fifth Avenue so two things I
want to say about this this is very
relevant to impeachment what I mean by
that is impeachment will only remove
Donald Trump more quickly than voting
him out in November of 2020 which is
just 12 months away at this point if
Trump truly loses the support of the
Republican Party and we're only 12
months away we're probably coming to the
end of that window as well because
remember Republican senators are tools
they are worthless bottom feeders who
put their fingers to the wind and
they're not going to do what is right
for the country they are going to do
what is politically expedient if the
Republican base turns against Trump okay
Republican senators might also turn
against Trump but 62 percent of
Republicans are telling us that they
will never ever no matter what Trump
does turn against him never mind by the
way that normal people already
have turned against Trump for what he's
already done 62% of Trump is say they
will never turn against Trump
that means no impeachment Republican
senators are not going to jump on the
bandwagon so to speak even if deep down
they think it's the right thing to do if
nearly two-thirds of Trumpets never get
behind impeachment so it's time to
really start thinking about legacy here
in a sense whatever age group you are in
next year an election year whether it's
Millennials whether you'll be 18 and
it'll be your first opportunity to vote
in a presidential election whether
you're a baby boomer everyone what is
the legacy of your generation going to
be with regard to what you did about
Trump did you support him Wow Wow
did you stand aside and allow him to be
elected still not good or are you
actually going to be a part of the
solution because 2020 is a potential
inflection point okay everything that
has been building Democrats taking the
house in 2018 Democrats with some big
wins yesterday in state elections in
Kentucky and in Virginia and one of the
narrowest defeats for Democrats in
Mississippi in the gubernatorial
election in a very long time this is all
building to a possible inflection point
in 2020 and there's two ways that it
could go either we start to pull back
the insanity and go back to something
that makes sense or a little more sense
or do we go completely off the rails
into a lame-duck Trump that will be
further uninhibited that will be more
corrupt that will be more bribery so
don't know if that's really a word I
know which side I'm going to be on I
hope most of you will be joining me on
that right side of history we will have
a poll about this on our Instagram page
at david pakman show follow at david
pakman show on instagram by the way
while you're there I we've been having a
problem at my place with people using
our trash cans and I decided to take
action and concoct a little flowchart to
help people figure out if they should be
using my trash cans I posted it to my
Instagram page at David Pakman check it
out we'll take a quick
and a lot more to discuss today I am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka stakes the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a fifteen minute
audio book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube i've put a link in the
description i have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink is calm slash Pakman that's
B Li NK is t.com /pa ke ma n